la cour d'assises a pris aujourd'hui des
allures de laboratoire c'est en ses murs
que froidement avec le recul des années
la justice a entrepris de disséquer
presque seconde par seconde une bagarre
de celle qui aurait dû rester une simple
anecdote d'un samedi soir un peu arrosée
en clair qui a fait quoi et pourquoi la
défense est à la manoeuvre
si l'auteur des coups de couteau ne fait
aucun doute ses complices jouent gros
ils bafouillent ne se souviennent plus
vraiment l'avocat général s'en agace les
proches de la victime souffre en silence
on doit être juste dans toutes choses
que ce soit pour nos enfants
que ce soit pour nous même ce soit pour
tout le monde ce qu avant tout on fait
partie de l'humanité on est des êtres
humains et on doit aimer sur les points
les autres ce qu'on aime pour nous mêmes
donc on doit être juste moi ce que
j'attends de ce procès tout s'est passé
maintenant c'est passé on reviendra pas
en arrière mamadou il reviendra pas mais
que chacun sus il y a le client refoulé
le frère qui arrivent pour l'aider la
bande qui l'accompagnent en aucun cas on
était là pour en découdre on a rien
compris
on ne savait pas pour le couteau il y a
pourtant bien eu bagarre sitôt le groupe
constitué un coup de coup de poing dit
maudit que je qualifierais de l'ach a
été décoché est enclenché une scène de
violence et au cours de scènes de
violence il y en a un qui à
tourbillonner autour du groupe qui a
porté deux coups de couteau mortels
j'ignorais qu'il était là j'ignorais
qu'il était armé j'ignorais encore plus
qu'il avait l'intention de tuer
participé à une bagarre à mains nues
pourquoi pas mais accepter le fait que
dans cette bagarre une personne sorte un
couteau
soit vous y êtes associé vous le savez
et vous en supporter la responsabilité
soit vous n'en savez rien et vous vous
retrouvez pris dans une affaire de
meurtre qui ne vous concerne pas
la défense plaidera donc l'acquittement
du chef de complicité de meurtre un choc
auquel se préparent les proches de
mamadou un jeune homme qui travaillait
pour financer son doctorat de sport on a
bu voulait de mal à personne il était
jovial et j'ai aussi pensé à sa famille
une maman qui envoie son fils à des
milliers de kilomètres mon fils va
étudier comme ça demain tu seras
quelqu'un comme ça de mutu pourrait
aider ta famille de mais tu pourras et
des dix heures tu pourra m'aider moi ta
moment à la place de ça c'est un circuit
que l'on ramène à sa maman
une maman toujours bloqué au sénégal le
verdict est attendu vendredi